hey this is presh tolwalker this was an
actual question for one hundred thousand
dollars on the game show Who Wants to Be
a Millionaire
when multiplied by itself which number
is equal to one two three four five six
seven eight nine eight seven six five
four three two one
there are four answer choices and bear
with me because I'm going to read them
aloud exactly as I read them on the game
show answer Choice a 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1.
answer Choice B one one one one one one
one one one one one one
answer Choice c one one one one one one
one one one one one one one one and
answer Choice d one one one one one one
one one one one one one one one one one
so which answer is it remember you're
answering this on a game show so there's
time pressure where people are looking
at you you have to give an answer in a
reasonable amount of time
you can't use a calculator so what is
the correct answer
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so this question was on Who Wants To Be
A Millionaire in the U.S Whiz Kids week
and the contestant was so just wagley
this aired in November of 2016 and I
will mention that if you were watching a
mind your decisions video in December of
2015 you would have seen a video about
the beauty of mathematics where I shared
exactly a pattern that is used in this
question you would have instantly known
that the answer is a number which has
exactly nine repeated digits of one and
you would have instantly been able to
say that the correct answer choice is B
so you never know when mathematical
facts like this will come in handy so
keep watching and maybe you'll pick up
an answer that'll come in handy in the
future
so anyway why does this pattern even
happen we have one times one is equal to
1 11 times 11 equals 121 101 squared is
equal to one two three two one
if you have a number which has K digits
of one squared so we have four digits of
one here this is one two three four
three two one and the pattern continues
as we go all the way up to nine digits
now the pattern actually will continue
even more but you start carrying over
the digits the maximum digit we could
have is nine so the numbers look a
little bit different
but this is an amazing pattern now why
does it happen a good way to visualize
this is using multiply by lines so if
you have one times one we just have one
line multiplied by one line that gives
us one intersection which is one
now what about 11 times 11
. for the first number 11 we'll draw one
line for the tens digit we'll then leave
some space and then draw another line
for the other one
for the other number we draw the lines
in the other direction
so for the tens digit of 11 we draw one
line
then we leave some space and draw the
other line for the units digit
now Mark every time any of the lines
intersect with each other
we will now count vertically aligned
intersections
on the left there is one intersection in
the middle there are two intersections
and on the right there is one
intersection
and this means that 11 times 11 is equal
to one hundred and twenty one
now what about 111
so we have three lines for one number we
have three lines for the other number
and we get all of these intersections so
we count vertically aligned
intersections
so here's one here's two here's three
here's two and one
and one hundred and eleven multiplied by
itself is equal to one two three two one
and now you can see the pattern is going
to continue because we're creating this
symmetrical lattice between the two
numbers
so in this one we're going to get one
two three four three two one
if we have one one one one one that is
five digits of one multiplied by itself
we get this Square lattice and this will
be equal to one two three four five four
three two one and that's why the pattern
will continue it'll actually continue
indefinitely but once you get where the
vertical column will have more than nine
intersections you'll start getting carry
over so the numbers will look a little
bit different now professional
mathematicians have written about
patterns like this this particular
pattern where we have one two three
going up to K and then going back down
to one these are known as wonderful demo
numbers the name is due to cuprika
writing about them and this particular
paper is from ganji car and capricar now
why is the name called demlo some people
believe there's a town called dombile in
Maharashtra India and that became
shortened to be demo
so in any case these are very
interesting things mathematically
now how exactly did soja solve the
problem on the show he didn't know this
interesting bit of trivia so he came up
with an amazing method and I want to
share that with you
so he first started thinking about what
would happen if he multiplied two digit
numbers so let's just say 20 by 40. so
20 by 40 is equal to 800. so he thought
in his head that well we have one zero
and twenty one zero and forty and we end
up with two zeros in the answer so when
you multiply you're kind of adding the
number of zeros together
so then he looked at the number that we
need to attain so one two three four
five six seven eight nine eight seven
six five four three two one
so you can count there are nine digits
plus eight digits which is a total of 17
digits
so if you have a number multiplied by
itself to get to 17 digits how can you
do that so let's look at answer Choice C
he thought well this answer is actually
very close to 10 billion it's larger
than 10 billion so this is 10 to the
power of 10. now what would happen if
you take 10 to the power of 10
multiplied by 10 to the power of 10
you would get 10 to the power of 20 you
add these exponents now 10 to the power
of 20 is a number that has 20 zeros
now if you have a number that is 20
zeros it would have more than 17 digits
in total
so this is too big c cannot possibly be
the answer
so where do we go from there we can go
to the next answer choice of B
so answer Choice B is approximately
equal to 100 million which is 10 to the
power of 8. now 10 to the power of 8
multiplied by 10 to the power of 8 is
equal to 10 to the power of 16.
so this will be a number that has 16
zeros in the answer and that would be a
17 digit number this is exactly what we
want so soja said okay I'm going to have
answer Choice B that is my final answer
and in fact this is the correct answer
so I think it's interesting that even if
you don't know the exact way to get the
answer you can use the tool of
estimation to figure out that b would be
the correct answer
amazing question and the problem just
goes to show you never know when
mathematics will be important in your
future
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]